Okay, so we're beginning at October the 8th, 1906.
The cross is to man as the rain is to the horse.
It is the most interesting image.
>> In other words, the Lord is saying we have to be rained in,
and the only thing that does it effectively is the cross.
In other words, the only thing that stops us up short
and makes us think and maybe turn in a different direction
that we should turn in is the cross.
So this is a reality check for all of us.
And Louisa said, "I was in my usual state blessed.
Jesus came for just a little and told me.
My daughter, the cross is to the person
as the rain is to the horse."
What would happen to the horse if man did not use a rain?
It would be untamed, unrestrained, and would go
from precipice to precipice as we see our society going today.
To the point of becoming fierce and noxious to man
and to itself.
On the other hand, with the rain, it can be conducted.
It becomes tame.
It walks straight.
I love that one.
Serves the needs of man as a faithful friend
and stays safe for many precipice
because man keeps it and protects it.
That's the way the cross is for man.
That very interesting.
The cross tames him, restrains him,
arrests the course of his hurling himself
along the paths of passions which he feels within himself
and which devour him like fire.
So instead of raging against God and hurting himself,
the cross dampens his passions, softens him,
leads him, that's conduct, and serves the glory of God
and his own salvation.
All of it wasn't for the cross which by its mercy,
divine providence holds as a reign in order to restrain man.
All how many more evils one would see in humanity.
Isn't that unbelievable?
So I want to put Colossians 1.20 there at the end.
Colossians 1.20 and Galatians 6.14.
Therefore even though we don't like the cross,
as they say, it's good for you.
And you can see why no matter what you did to escape,
you didn't succeed.
Now human beings try to escape the cross all the time
in doing all kinds of stuff.
And I love this business that they say,
you know, I am going on an exotic holiday.
And what they don't remember at all
is that they pat themselves and they bring the problems.
The problems are not in the case.
And the problems are not in the airplane.
And the problems are not in the country
are going to-- you're carrying them in your heart.
And you can be just as miserable on an exotic holiday
as you are at home because you haven't solved the problem.
Something about it, the geographically escaped it all.
It took a little away from it.
OK, so October the 10th, 1906.
This is a very important one, VIP.
Everything to be done for Jesus and given to him.
This morning, blessed Jesus made himself
seen within a torrent of light.
Now you know the torrent of light is divine will at this stage.
And it's 1 John 1 5.
Just put DW beside it, torrent of light.
And in the higher volumes, Louisa will try and describe
this torrent of light that she finds herself in.
And creatures were inundated with this light
because the divine will is present to everyone
and is everywhere.
In such a way that all human actions
received the attitude of operating from this light.
In other words, all the living activities on the earth
comes from the sun beaming down on top of us.
Is that correct?
OK, so the sun is used in all of these writings
as a symbol of the divine will without outside of which none
of us could exist and none of us could do anything.
That's the light beaming down on top of us, OK?
While I was seeing this, blessed Jesus told me, my daughter,
I am concurring that is agreeing continuously
in the slightest human action.
In other words, you can't blink the eyes unless the divine
will actually permit it.
So beside that, put your John 15 5
without him I can do nothing.
John 15 5.
And then underneath that, Philippians 4 13.
But I can do all things with him.
Without him nothing with him everything.
So I am concurring continuously in the every slightest human
action be it a thought, a breath, or a movement.
But creatures not thinking about this attitude of mine
towards them, not only do they not
do all their works for me, from whom
they receive the life of their very operating or working,
but they attribute what they do to themselves.
I did this, this is my thing.
Or if only they thought about this continuous attitude of mine
towards them, they would not usurp what is mine.
So we learn rather quickly in the spiritual life
to say, the Lord has done that through me,
or the Lord has used me to do it.
But he is the origin of the thing.
And if they usurp what is mine, Jesus said,
it is to the detriment of my glory and of their good.
While they should be doing everything for me,
everything is done for love of him.
And we should give it to him sacrificially
and with his divine will.
Everything which is done for me can enter into me.
You see what he's saying.
And I keep it deposited within myself
to give it all to them in the next life.
So if something is done for him and given to him,
he can take it and hold on to it forever.
But everything which is not done for me cannot enter into me.
That would be useless actions, even if they're good ones.
Because those are not works that are worthy of mine.
Now he's telling you this in Volume 7
because he's building you up to living in the divine will
in Chapters 11 and 12 in which everything is done
on a divine level.
So he has to tell us as we go towards that,
that for us who are being called to live in the divine will,
just simply doing human things humanly is the waste of time.
But you don't make any judgment on anybody else
outside of the divine will.
You leave that, that's a different thing altogether.
So everything which is not done for me cannot enter into me
because those are not works of mine.
On the contrary, I feel nausea for them.
And I reject them even though there was my attitude.
In other words, you couldn't do it unless he enabled you.
So 1 Corinthians 12, 4 to 11, we can do all kinds of things.
But we need to do them for him and through him.
Because in that text, 1 Corinthians 12, 4 to 11,
St Paul says, the spirit working in one person does this,
and the spirit working in another person does that,
and the spirit working in another person does the other.
We see God as the origin.
And that's why I gave it that particular reference.
So October the 13th, 1906 talks about detachment
and the necessity of these writings.
As I was in my usual state, my good Jesus
made himself seen for a little while.
And he told me, my daughter, in order
to know whether a soul is stripped of everything,
it is enough to see this.
If holy or even indifferent desires arise within her,
and she is ready to sacrifice them to divine volition.
Now notice that the discernment that he is giving
is whether the actions are high or low,
that we will be willing to sacrifice them to the divine will.
And to do so with holy peace, that means that she is stripped.
But if she becomes disturbed and upset,
it means that she's keeping something for herself.
OK?
So because it's something you're holding on to,
and somebody wants to take from you, that will upset you.
But he says that people in the divine will
are happy to give all their actions and everything
to the Lord, so that's OK.
Having heard the word desire,
Louisa said, "My highest good, my desire,"
the strange thing is that Jesus is talking in general
about being free enough to offer everything to the divine will.
And Louisa has a particular thing in her head,
and she's going to pursue that.
Regardless of what Jesus is saying,
I've noticed that throughout the volumes,
once you get beyond volume 12, it gets better.
And when you go to volume 20, she forgets herself altogether.
So having heard the word desire, she said, "My highest good,
my desire, is that I would rather not write anymore."
This is only volume seven.
If she only knew, she has to go to 36.
"How it weighs on me, if it wasn't for fear of going out of your will
and of displeasing you, I wouldn't do it."
And he, breaking my words off.
Now, he normally doesn't caution like that, OK?
He added, "You do not want it, but I do want it."
OK.
Now, "I want it" means the divine will put DW beside that.
The divine will does want it, OK?
Louisa didn't, but God does.
"That which I say to you, and which you write out of obedience
for now," notice you are writing out of obedience for now.
Later on, she'd forget all of this, and she'd just write what the Lord gives her.
"Serves as a mirror for you, and for those who take part in directing you."
Now, the mirror is that they're going to see God and his actions,
and what he can do in a human life through their dealing with Louisa
and dealing with this.
When we are studying these writings, we have a mirror of what God is like
and how God relates to us and how God wants to build us up.
So, that's the divine mirror.
So, "That which you write, spoken by me, can be called a divine mirror."
You could actually put that as the heading for the entire 36 volumes.
And you would want to take this divine mirror away from my children.
I noticed that just changed creatures to children there.
"Watch it. Seriously, my daughter."
This is the first time she gets really ticked off.
OK, "Watch it seriously, my daughter, and do not want to restrict this mirror of grace
by not writing everything. Not only are you to not write anything,
but you must write everything."
He goes way beyond what she has said.
On hearing this, I remain confused and humiliated
with the great repugnance to write these last words of his,
because it was the first time she really got properly ticked off.
I think it's lovely, I don't know about you,
to hear of somebody at this high level of sanctity needing to be ticked off by the Lord.
I don't know about you, it makes me feel good.
Because when he has to tick me off, then I don't feel so bad.
So Louisa said she was confused in humiliations
with a great repugnance to write these last words,
but obedience absolutely imposed on me and I do it to obey.
In other words, she was told to write everything.
And so as soon as the priest gets the inkling that Jesus is demanding
that she write everything, the priest orders her,
and then she can do nothing further.
So October the 14th, 1906, self-esteem poisons grace.
Now Jesus is moving towards something which is a huge problem in the world today,
and it's called autolotry.
Have you ever heard of it?
A-U-T-O-L-A-T-R-Y.
It means worship of self.
A-U-T-O, you see, is myself.
Auto, and then idolatry is idealatry, and this is autolatry, idolatry.
It's idolatry of self.
Louisa will call it idolatrizing oneself.
Okay, it's the final insult to God, that instead of worshiping God
or even worshiping anything else, you'll worship yourself.
And to me the image of it is this, the selfie.
And it's just the attitude they take in taking the photograph
is an attitude of worship, worship of self.
It's actually very sad.
So, as I was in my usual state, I found myself outside of myself with baby Jesus
and he seemed to say to a priest.
Now the first paragraph is about this priest.
Self-esteem poisons grace in you and in others.
Now this is very important.
So, self-esteem poisons grace in the priest.
But since God wants to use the priest to reach others,
others are going to get everything contaminated with the self-esteem.
So, poisons others.
And what he's going to say is it actually destroys faith.
In fact, since you're office, since by your office you must administer grace.
If souls detect that what you say and do, you do in order to be esteemed
and it can easily be detected when this poison is present,
the priest does not enter alone but together with the poison you have.
Now, a glass of water is a very wonderful thing,
but a glass of water with even a few molecules of poison in it
is not a very wonderful thing, is it?
You've heard of the story of the cyanide sandwich, have you?
Okay, well it's a good example to give you if you're explaining things to others.
The cyanide sandwich, the bread is okay, the butter is okay,
the meat is okay or whatever else you have in it is okay.
It's just the cyanide, isn't it?
Everything else is okay.
Now, this self-esteem, the priest is okay, the vocation he has is okay,
the work he's doing is okay, the church is okay, what he's saying is okay,
but there's this poison in it.
And that poison just destroys everything.
That's what he's saying.
That's why I give you the cyanide sandwich example.
So, grace does not enter alone, but together with the poison that you have.
And instead of rising again to life, you find death.
In other words, he cannot give life.
Okay, so the next paragraph is very important.
I have a VIP on this paragraph alone, and it is that if you want to be filled with God,
you've got to be empty of self, it's about as simple as that.
So, again, come back to the glass with water.
If I have the glass filled with water and I want to fill it with milk,
the water has to go.
It's as simple as that.
The glass could only hold one or the other if I want to fill it with the liquid.
So, this is where we get my nothingness in your allness.
You know the expression in the Provenient Prayer?
Okay.
Then he added, "It's necessary that you strip yourself of everything.
That everything is the self.
It doesn't mean your house, your car, your job, your connections, your phone or anything else.
It doesn't mean anything either."
You must strip yourself of everything for you to be filled with the all.
So, notice the all and the nothing are the two things.
The all which is God.
And by having the all with you, you will give the all to those who will come to you.
Because you can only give what you have.
So, if you've only got self esteem and self idolatry, that's all you can give.
If you've thrown your nothingness into his allness,
then you have God filling your whole being and you can give him.
You will give the all to those who will come to you.
And in giving the all to others, you will find everything at your disposal.
In such a way that no one will be able to deny you anything.
Not even esteem.
Even more from human, you will have it divine.
In other words, you'll have the esteem of heaven, which be fits the all who dwells in you.
So, this is the all or nothing thing.
And one of the very good little aspirations to say during the day is,
"Lord, I throw my nothingness into your allness so that you have complete freedom to work in me."
Or if you don't want to say a full sentence like that,
once you say it once, then you say, "My nothingness into your allness."
He gets the message.
After this, I saw a soul in purgatory who upon seeing us hid and shunned us.
And the blushing she felt was such that she was as though crushed.
I was surprised, and instead of running to the baby, she would run away.
Jesus disappeared, and I drew near her asking the reason for this.
She was so ashamed that she couldn't offer a word, but I forced her.
I don't know how she did that.
And she told me, "Just justice of God for having sealed upon my forehead confusion
and such fear of his presence that I am forced to shun him.
I act against my own will because, while I am consumed with yearning for him,
another pain inundates me and I shun him.
O God, to see him and to shun him."
These are mortal and unutterable pains.
However, I have deserved these pains distinct from those of other souls
because in conducting a devout life, so this is someone living a spiritual life.
Many times, I made abuse by not receiving communion because of trifles, temptations,
coldness, fears, and sometimes even in order to be able to bring reasons
to my confession to let him hear that I wasn't receiving communion.
Now, notice the amount of attention to the self there.
So, in case that confuses you, just right beside itself, absorption.
Self-absorption.
It's very difficult to relate to somebody who's absorbed in themselves, isn't it?
Souls hold all this as nothing, but God judges it most severely.
It's because of the self-absorption and in order to get anywhere,
you've got to put the self aside.
And that's why it's given here to illustrate the second paragraph,
which was all about stripping yourself of the self to throw yourself into his allness.
So, souls don't consider this important, but God judges it most severely,
giving it pains which surpass the other pains because these are defects more directed to love,
a direct insult to love.
If you are in a marital relation with somebody
and that person is self-absorbed, are they sinning against love?
Yeah, because love is spontaneous going out of yourself to somebody else.
And, you know, if you're not pouring yourself out on another person,
the commitment you made to that person is not being fulfilled.
Am I talking English? Okay, it's exactly the same with the Lord.
Self-absorption is turning back on yourself,
and you're not actually loving yourself because it's like turning a river back.
It will not give life turning back.
It can only give life by going forward, you know.
And so turning attention back on yourself destroys you,
but it also destroys the relationship.
And a very selfish person makes a very unhappy home, don't they?
Because marriage doesn't survive a lack of love.
So this soul is describing it as this selfishness is directly opposite to loving,
so she was refusing to love.
And in heaven, now in these writings you'll be told as clear as day
that you can't get into heaven without love.
It's actually possible, because God is love.
Everything in heaven is love, okay?
And it's the only baggage you're allowed when you get on that airplane to go home.
No other baggage. All other baggage is for purgatory or elsewhere.
No other. And unfortunately some people only have hand baggage going to heaven.
Others only have purses.
In other words, the amount of love they have is too small.
In addition to this, Jesus Christ in the most blessed sacrament burns with love
and with the desire to give himself to souls.
He feels himself dying continuously with love.
And when the soul can draw near him to receive it, but does not,
or even more, she remains there indifferent with many useless pretexts.
That's people today who just wouldn't bother to go.
That's not convenient.
The affront and the displeasure he receives are such
that he feels restless, burning and cannot give vent to his flames of love understood.
He feels as though suffocated by his own love because he can't give it to anybody else.
Because if you truly love someone else and that person
prevents you from showing your love, that's the most shocking pain, isn't it?
So he feels as though suffocated by his own love,
finding no one with whom to share it and almost gone mad.
He keeps repeating, "The excesses of my love are neglected.
Even more, they are forgotten.
Even the ones who call themselves my spouses, they would be the priests in religious
and anyone living his spiritual life, have no yearning to receive me
and to let me pour myself out with them at least in nothing am I requited."
Now in the divine will he asks us to make up to him for the losses that other souls leave to him,
so we substitute for them.
And then he said, "Oh, oh, oh, I am not loved. I am not loved."
Now if any of you have studied the life of St. Francis of Assisi
in his final months when he had received the Stigmata,
one of the times that he was seen sort of elevating off the ground,
he was heard because one of the brothers hid in the woods to see what on earth was going on.
Francis always wanted to be alone.
That's the instinct of a lover, isn't it, to be alone with the beloved?
And he heard Francis shouting, "Love is not loved, love is not loved, love is not loved."
Now that's what Jesus is saying, "I am not loved, I'm not loved."
That means God who is love is not getting a response from human beings.
And so to have me purged of this defect the soul said,
"The Lord has made me share in the pain which he suffers when souls do not receive him."
Isn't that interesting?
That's an insight into purgatory, I don't think you'd get anywhere else.
So just take note of it that the participation in the Passion of Jesus
that was refused in the life was offered to this soul in purgatory
to see was there any possibility that they could come around to actually loving?
They've got to come around to love.
It is a pain, it is a sorrow, it is a fire.
Such that it can be said that the very fire of purgatory compared to it is nothing.
That's very interesting.
So you're hearing purgatory and purgatory.
And you're hearing that there are different things going on in purgatory.
The impression you get from listening to people is that it's a fire
and everybody goes in and you get scarched.
Here you're being told what happens is very particular.
It's very interesting.
And you'll be told that in other volumes as well.
Because one of the priests who guided Louisa had to have a little time in purgatory after he died.
And she said, "What are you doing in purgatory?"
He said, "I needed a dip."
He needed a shower.
So everybody's experience there is particular.
So Louisa said she found herself inside of herself all stupefied thinking about the pain of that soul
while here with us that means on earth.
And electing community is really held as nothing.
That's something.
October the 16th, 1906.
How each good is a distinct melody in heaven.
It's very interesting now.
Having neglected to write what follows obedience commanded me to do it,
she's been told so often to write everything.
And she is so reluctant to write.
She's got to be forced to do it.
It's a bit fascinating.
I seemed to be outside of myself and it seemed that there was a special feast in heaven.
Now the reason why she doesn't want to write is that when she experiences heaven for the first time,
she feels that if she writes it, you know, that she's being the proudest soul on the planet,
that's her resistance to writing it.
It seemed I was singing with the very blessed, that it seems that she's claiming to be a saint.
You know what I mean?
Because up there there's no need to learn.
Isn't that lovely?
But one feels as though an infusion in one's interior.
Now anyone who has given testimony of an out of the body, a near-death experience in which they've gone deeply into communion with God,
that they understood things instantly.
That, you know, the moment you'd formulate a thought, the knowledge is there.
So you feel an infusion in one's interior.
Now many people living a truly mystical life get infused knowledge.
That's knowledge given to you that you have not learned.
And you understand things and all you know is that you understand it.
But nobody has told you.
And if afterwards you find it in a book or you find somebody else saying it, you're amazed
because this was given to you directly, you know.
So that's infused knowledge, but infused knowledge is normal on the other side.
And whatever the others sing or do, one is able to do it as well.
Now it seems to me that each blessed is a key.
They stop my music now.
So this is a musical note.
That is a melody himself.
But all are in harmony among themselves, though each one is different from the other.
Just like you make up a huge orchestra and they're all different and the harmony is fantastic.
Okay.
One sings the notes of praise.
One the notes of glory.
One the notes of thanksgiving.
One the notes of blessings.
But all these notes reunite into one single note, which is the note of love.
It seems that one single voice reunites all these voices and ends with the word love.
This cry love is such a sweet and strong resounding, is a sweet and strong resounding that all
the other voices remain as though extinguished in this canticle of love.
It seems that all the blessed were made ecstatic, drowsy, awake, drowsy and awake.
Interesting, isn't it?
Inebriated by this cry or chant love.
It was high, harmonious, beautiful, which deafened the whole of heaven.
They participated, one would say, in one more paradise.
But who were the fortunate ones who cried out more loudly and who made this note love resound
in everything and who brought great happiness to heaven itself.
They were the ones who had loved the Lord more when they lived on the earth.
Now, interesting.
It's the level of love you have, determines the level of paradise you have as well.
They were not the notes that were done, who had done great things, penances, miracles,
and no, never. Love alone is what surpasses everything and leaves everything behind.
She's very much in tune with St. Therese of Lesus, who says that if you pick up a pin off the floor
out of pure love for God, that it's worth all the projects on the planet.
Okay.
So, I want to give you all our scriptures for this.
John 1334, that's the command to love as Jesus loves.
John 159, as the Father has loved me, so I have loved you, so you are to love each other.
One Corinthians 1313, the greatest is faith, hope, and love, and the greatest of these is love.
And then one Corinthians 14, one, you must want love more than anything else.
And Ephesians 3, 16 to 21, founded in love, built on love, you come to a completion of Ephesians 3, 16 to 21,
and you come to the fullness of love in the fullness of Christ, Ephesians 3, 16 to 21.
Okay. So, love alone is what surpasses everything and leaves everything behind.
So, it is the one who loves much. Now, that is Luke 747.
This woman was forgiven much because she loved much, do you remember?
The one who has loved much, 47, not one who does much will be more pleasing to the Lord.
Now, on earth we have the exact opposite feeling.
We think that the one who does great things is the great one.
And the one who just hides themselves away and loves the Lord and sacrifices themselves for souls that they are doing nothing.
Okay. And the Lord says it's the other way around.
If you take the caramelites and the poor clairs and other communities and communities of men as well,
who hide themselves away for life in an absolutely incredibly sacrificial way of life,
he says that their love is what keeps the church alive.
So, Louisa said, it seems I'm speaking nonsense. She always says that when she's talking about something
that other people won't have heard. But what can I do? It's obedience default.
Who doesn't know that the things from up there cannot be spoken down here?
That's one Corinthians 2, 9. The things that I has seen and ear has heard,
and the incredible things that God has prepared for those who love him.
But we find it impossible to actually pull it into words.
Okay. So, she said, in order not to speak more nonsense, I stop here.
Now, she doesn't realize that she hasn't yet obeyed.
Why? She was told to write everything. Who told her to write everything? Jesus.
But if you have a huge problem about something,
that problem prevents you from actually hearing the fullness of what somebody is asking of you.
Does that make sense? Yes. And it's only as you go
and make efforts to try and do the thing
that you begin to realize the implications of what has been asked.
It's only when you get up to the really high volumes
that she'll do four full-scale pages as one message.
Now she's talking. In other words, she's really explaining things.
Whereas these very short messages, it's different. She's only giving you some things.
So continuing this thought, October 18, 1906,
it's the hidden works that the Lord loves.
As I was in my usual state, "Blessed Jesus just barely came and told me,
my daughter, the works which I like the most are the hidden works
because free from any human spirit
they contain such preciousness within themselves
that I keep them as the choicest inside of my heart."
This came home to me very much one year when RTE did a telethon
and they were announcing hour by hour such and such a body
as given 10,000 such and such a body as given 5,000 such and it was all the big numbers.
RTE incredible, RTE incredible, RTE incredible.
In a few days later, I visited a family and discovered that their one and only son
had just got a job for the first time in his life.
And during that telethon, he got his first pay packet.
And only that somebody noticed it and told his mother, "We wouldn't know."
He slipped the whole pay packet in, that opening.
Leaving himself with nothing to buy food for the week.
And to me it said the widows might.
You know, there was this 10,000, this 5,000, this whatever.
And corporations offering this out in the other.
Your first pay packet, there's nothing more precious.
You know, I mean you earned it.
It's yours for the first time in your whole life.
This is yours.
And you offered the whole thing.
He just hadn't even opened the packet.
Now I think that's what the Lord's talking about.
And the little things that people do where they don't want anybody to know.
They don't even want the receiver to know that they did it.
He says, "Don't let your left hand know what your right hand is doing."
And that's to keep the human thing out.
The praise and the blame and the self glory and all the rest,
all the stuff that destroys us.
Okay.
My son did something similar after his first year of work.
He got attacked for eight or seven times in jail.
Yeah, I'll hear it later. Is that okay?
So these hidden works are free from the any human spirit.
They contain such preciousness within themselves that I keep them as the choices
inside of my heart, so much so that in comparing a thousand external
and public works with one internal and hidden work.
Look at that.
He got trouble to give us that explanation.
The one thousand external ones remain below the single internal work
because in the external works the human spirit always takes part.
Okay.
So that's quite a statement from the Lord.
So October the 20th, 1906.
Jesus lament over the state of his priests, his ministers.
So he talks about the sins of priests and the consequences because of their position.
The higher your position, the greater the consequence of a mistake that you make.
As I was in my usual state, I found myself inside a church
in which there were many people attending sacred services.
In the meantime, it seemed that by the authority of the government,
other people were entering to profane, notice with the authority of the government,
to profane the holy place.
Some were jumping and some were using violence and some were laying hands
sacrilegiously on the most holy sacrament and on the priests.
That's a violent attack, isn't it?
On seeing this, I cried and prayed, saying to the Lord,
"Do not permit that they arrive at profaning your sacred temples
because who knows how many terrible chastisements you would unload upon your creatures
because of these horrendous sins?"
Now the people attacking are obviously politically or socially motivated.
But while I was saying this, Jesus told me, my daughter,
the cause of all these enormous crimes, because one sin is the cause
and chastisement of making others fall into more sins,
have been the sins of priests.
Now, if he's talking about the sins of priests,
you look at the date, it's 1906.
You have to remember that this is the time of the communist infiltration of the church,
where they planted atheists in seminaries
and these atheists were paid by communists to survive in the seminaries
and they introduced homosexuality into the priesthood.
So you now have an idea of what they're actually talking about, okay?
So the image that she got of the church being violently attacked
is actually happening, the violence is really happening on a spiritual level
because all of this was done secretly and quietly and all the rest of it.
Now, if the priests are sinning like this,
they have been the first to profane my holy temple,
hiddenly, with sacrilegious masses.
See, sexual immorality among them would bring the sacrilegious masses
and by mixing impure acts with the administration of the sacraments
and under the appearance of holy things,
they have reached the point of profaning not only my temples of stone
but of profaning and using violence on my living temples.
Now, the first thing that came across my head reading that was pedophilia, okay?
Because if I mention homosexuality and sexual sin,
then you remember pedophilia, okay?
But the living temple of God, I want to give you one Corinthians 3, 16.
No, you're not that you are the temple of the living God.
One Corinthians 3, 16.
Also, 6, 16.
One Corinthians.
So they are profaning and using violence on my living temples,
which are the souls and are profaning my very body.
That's the body of Christ, okay?
The secular, that's the laity, those that are not priests and religions,
have somehow perceived all this and not seeing in them the light that was necessary for their journey
or rather they have found nothing but darkness.
They have been left so clouded as to lose the beautiful light of faith
and that's been happening quite a lot, the loss of faith, people walking away.
Okay, and without light, it is no wonder that they reach such grave excesses.
So I want to give you Matthew 15 verses 1 to 9,
where the Lord spoke about the hypocrisy of the religious leaders on his own day.
Matthew 16, 12,
and the whole of Matthew 23, where Jesus gives a terrible indictment of the scribes and Pharisees.
Therefore he said, "Pray for priests, that they may be light for the people."
Now, the light of the world you are told, the church was told to be, is Matthew 5 verses 14 to 16.
So that as the light rises again, the laity may acquire life and may see the errors that they commit
and by seeing them that they will feel disgusted to commit these grave excesses,
which will be the cause of grave chastisements.
Now, you've been given a kind of an order there.
If the priest goes into sin, then there are sacrilegious masses,
then there's interference with the sacraments, people lose faith.
They start attacking the church. That's where we're at, isn't it?
Okay. So October the 23rd, 1906.
And this is fascinating, totally fascinating, if you heard what I've just read.
How in these times everything is effeminate.
Uh-oh. And he's talking about priests.
Is that remarkable?
And it's the loss of the masculine.
If we lose the masculine, we lose all leadership.
We lose everything. God put Adam in charge of the earth.
Eve was his helper.
And society has turned that upside down today.
So the more we move towards unisex and gender confusion.
Okay. You have this effeminate thing.
As I was in my usual state, my adorable Jesus came for a little.
And all oppressed and afflicted, he wanted to pour his bitterness into me.
Okay. Then he told me, my daughter, the bitterness, we don't say bitterness as.
The bitterness that people give me is such that I cannot contain it.
This is why I wanted to share it with you.
In these times, it's only 1906, that makes me shocked, you know.
Everything is effeminate.
Priests themselves seem to have lost the masculine characteristic.
Look at that.
And acquired the feminine characteristic, what would you call them? Gay priests.
This is 1906. Not 2006.
So only rarely can a masculine priest be found.
The rest are all effeminate.
There's the death of the priesthood for you.
Ah, in what a deplorable state poor humanity is.
Having said this, he disappeared. I myself do not comprehend the meaning of this, naturally enough.
She wouldn't understand, but unfortunately we do.
So October the 25th, 1906.
For one who receives it, grace is light.
See, grace is God, an outpouring of God.
Light is the divine will. It's an outpouring of God.
And God is also fire, the third person of the less affinity, okay?
So continuing my usual state, I found myself outside of myself,
and there seemed to be people who wanted to crucify me.
While they were laying me on the cross, I saw, notice you doesn't have a problem with that.
I'd at least ask them who they were and why they thought, you know, they should be approaching me, you know.
While they were laying me on the cross, I saw our Lord within me, and as I laid myself, he laid himself, too.
So in my hands, there were his hands, and the nail was piercing my hand and his.
Now, it's not unusual for people living a deep spiritual life to have some aspect of what is being described here.
I actually know people who have experienced their own hand and the Lord's hand behind it and the two hands nailed to the cross.
Other people have experienced entering in and experiencing the crown of thorns.
It's a special way of identifying with this experience,
but I just want to tell you, in case you think, well, that's Louise and she's up there, that could never happen to us, it can.
It can.
And the thing is, it could be happening to you in a crisis of pain or difficulty that you're going through,
and you wouldn't give it this kind of an interpretation.
So in one split second, the Lord will show you your hand and his, nailed to the cross.
So that you then understand, okay, this is bigger than I thought.
It's not just the external circumstances.
I think it's important to say that in case we just leave Louise up there by herself.
So in my hands were his hands and the nail was piercing my hand.
And whatever I suffered, he would suffer as well.
Because he has just told us back there that he has to concur with everything that we do, otherwise we can't do it.
The pain that those nails notice without a point.
Now she said that in the hours of the Passion as well, that in order to increase the pain, a nail without a point would crush the bones in a most awful way.
A nail without a point gave us, was such that I felt I was dying, but how sweet to die together with Jesus.
I only feared that I wouldn't die.
Now as they were about to crucify my feet, Jesus escaped me from within and was now in front of me.
My suffering took on the shapes of light.
In other words, she's beginning to see this on a higher plane, on the divine plane.
And placed themselves before the Lord as though in an act of adoration, now her acts in this are placed as acts of adoration before the Lord.
After this he told me, "My daughter, for one who receives it, grace is light.
It is way, it is nourishment, it is strength, it is relief.
But for one who does not receive it, in addition to the fact that he finds no light,
he finds the ground missing under his feet, remaining on an empty stomach and without strength.
Grace converts into fire and chastisement for a world that absolutely rejects it.
Now before we go on any further, for the bit I've just read from Grace's light, 1 Peter 4.10, 1 Peter 4.10, Hebrews 4.16,
and 2 Timothy 2.1.
Now that covers the section that says Grace's light, it is the way, it is nourishment for us, it is strength for our souls, it is relief.
But for one who does not receive it, in addition to the fact that he gets no light, he also feels the ground missing under his feet.
In other words, we can't get anywhere spiritually without Grace, it's not actually possible.
Remaining on an empty stomach so that there's no food for the soul, without strength, therefore they have no ability to deal with temptation.
Not only that, but Grace converts into fire of chastisement.
While he was saying this, a torrent of light came out of his hand, which descended upon the people, and this light remained light for some, and for some turned into fire.
See the difference, some people can receive it, and it will become light and grace and way and nourishment and everything, and for the others it will be chastisement.
2 Peter 3.18. 2 Peter 3.18. I should have given you this one first, 2 Peter 1.2.
And then I should have given you this one definitely first, 1 Peter 5.5.
That's a backways order. I think that is very important that when God, you see Grace is the Lord himself, he can only give himself, he doesn't have anything else.
So if the Lord pours himself out on us and we reject it, then there are consequences to that.
And people nowadays don't want to know there are consequences to their actions.
October 28, 1906, everything which is light comes from God, because God is light.
Everything that is dark comes from the dark kingdom.
Having received communion, I found myself within a great light, it was Jesus himself, 1 John 1, 5.
You can also put John 9, 3, I think it is, I am the light of the world.
Okay, and this is another one in John 8. He said to me, "My daughter, everything which is light is all mine, because God is light."
It's not of the creature. It happens, or we would say it's the same as a person who is invested by the rays of the sun.
If you wanted to attribute the light which he enjoys to himself, it would be foolish and brainless because the light is coming from the sun and belongs to the sun.
However, there is this, that that person, instead of enjoying the light of the sun, could say, "I want to walk in the shade and withdraw from the light while the soul in withdrawing from the light becomes darkness, and darkness can produce nothing but evil."
That's John 3, 19. That they choose the darkness instead of the light, John 3, 19.
So, notice the emphasis here is on we have the freedom to go forward and accept the light, accept the gifts of God, or we have the freedom to reject, but we have to take the consequences.
Because if we were given the gift of free will, yes, you can use it, but there are consequences.
And we try to teach that to children, I hope, as early as possible. You are free, but you've got to take the consequences.
If you put your hand into boiling water, you've got to take the consequences.
So, October 31, 1906, how for each suffering the soul acquires one more kingdom within herself.
This is kind of new language for us, isn't it?
So, I want to give you Romans 5, 17. Put it under the heading. How to reign in life with Christ. Romans 5, 17.
Continue in my usual state, "Blessed Jesus came in passing and told me this.
My daughter, each suffering that the soul suffers is one more dominion that she acquires over herself.
In fact, patience in suffering is regime or rule or dominion.
And by ruling herself, the more she suffers, the more dominion she acquires.
She does nothing but expand and enlarge her kingdom of heaven, acquiring immense riches for eternal life.
So, for each additional pain you suffer, consider that you acquire one more kingdom for the soul, a kingdom of grace,
which corresponds to a kingdom of virtue or of glory."
Now, I think that what he's talking about there is that when you suffer, that suffering calls forth different responses from you,
from the nations, forgiveness, kindness, wisdom, all kinds of things, and he calls each one of them a kingdom,
and you're conquering a kingdom.
So, I want to give you Revelation 3, 20 to 22 there. Revelation 3, 20 to 22.
So, now we go on to November 6, 1906 and put a big VIP on this one.
The faith and the hope of the soul who lives in the divine will. So, we're moving forward nicely now.
More and more, he will tell you about living in the divine will.
I was praying according to my usual way that whatever I do, I do it as if I were doing it with the Lord and with his own intentions.
Now, there you go. There's your starter point. There's your number one point.
I do it with the Lord and with his own intentions.
So, as I was reciting the creed, I love this, as I was reciting the creed and without realizing it myself,
I was saying that I intended to have the faith of Jesus Christ.
Where did he get the faith?
To repair for so many unbeliefs and to impotrate the gift of faith for all.
At that moment, he moved in my interior and he said, "You're wrong. I had neither faith nor hope."
Why? He is fate.
And he is hope. We have to have faith in him. He was God.
So, he was in possession. He didn't need hope.
Hope was for those who are reaching out to possess.
I had neither faith nor hope nor could I have them because I was God himself.
I was only love one John 4-7.
God is love one John 4-7.
I love when Louisa makes mistakes like that.
She keeps on thinking, you know, I have to imitate him and then imitate him in something he can't be.
So, in other words, our prayers have to be accurate. They have to be correct.
Okay.
On hearing love, I liked so much to be able to only love.
And not paying attention, I spoke some more nonsense, which was, "My Lord, I would like to be like you all love."
This is very much the same as Saint Therese and nothing else.
And he added, "This is my goal because our whole transformation is from selfishness to love, isn't it?"
Okay.
"This is my goal and this is why I often speak to you about perfect resignation.
Because by living in my will, the soul acquires the most heroic love underline.
And reaches the point of loving me with my own love."
You see, there's that centering into the divine will, so you love him with his own love.
She becomes all love, and becoming all love, she is in continuous contact with me.
So, she is with me, she is in me, she is for me, and she does everything I want.
I want to give you John 14, 20 to 21 there.
You and me and I and you, both completely one.
Okay?
So, she is with me, she is in me, and she is for me, she does everything I want.
Nor does she move or desire anything but my will, in which all the love of the eternal one is enclosed.
You need to underline that again, all the love of the eternal one is enclosed in the divine will.
And in which she herself remains enclosed.
By living in this way, the soul almost comes to the point of dissolving faith and hope.
Why would that?
She has entered into possession, yeah, she's entered into possession where hope is not needed.
Now notice, he says almost because most of us might get to the point where it's 100%, do you know what I mean?
But with Louisa, it would have been because she comes to live of the divine will, or we would say from the divine will.
The soul no longer feels in contact with faith and hope.
Since she lives of the will of God, what does she have to believe if she has found it?
You've arrived.
And she's made it, that's the divine will, her food.
And what does she have to hope for if she's already possessing it by living it?
Not outside of God, but in God. I put Galatians 2.20 there, I no longer live, Christ lives in me.
Galatians 2.20.
Therefore, true and perfect resignation is the mark of sure predestination.
This is a very important statement.
True and perfect resignation is the mark of sure predestination, and the sure possession that the soul has of God.
And then he said, "Think down and over carefully."
I think that's the most fantastic piece there and requires you to read it over and over again.
Is that okay?
And that's what he wants in bringing us into the divine will.
You have found God, so faith becomes something you actually have acquired.
Sorry, you don't need it in the sense of believing something you haven't experienced,
but you're now experiencing it.
And since hope, you have possession of God, then you're not reaching out for something you don't have.
So notice when you read 1 Corinthians 13, and you're told what love is, in the end he says,
"There is faith, hope and love, and the greatest of these is love."
And he tells you afterwards that faith and hope will have to go, only love remains.
So what the Lord wants is for us to experience that in our lifetime.
He doesn't want us to wait until later.
So Louisa said she remained as though enchanted, and she said to herself,
"Really? Can one reach this?"
And she almost doubted, saying, "Maybe he wanted to tempt me to see what I would do,
to give me the field to speak more nonsense, and to show me where my pride reaches."
You see, this is the first time this has been mentioned in the church,
so naturally she was saying, "You sure?"
However, it is good to speak some nonsense, at least one pushes him to say something.
And receives the good of hearing his voice, which restores one from death to life.
And I kept thinking of what other nonsense I could say.
He was trying to think of something.
At that moment he moved again, and he said, "It is you who want to tempt me, not I you.
Let's do it around in me, 613. We don't tempt God."
And also you have Deuteronomy 613.
And you have Matthew 4 and Luke 4.
Remember the temptations of Jesus?
Jesus told the demon, "You do not tempt the Lord your God."
Remember?
And besides, we just stopped doubting about my truths, and he kept silent.
I felt confused, Louisa said, and I kept thinking of what he had told me.
Who can say everything?
These are things that cannot be expressed.
They're completely new to her, and they're going to be completely new to the priest who receives them.
And they're going to be completely new to the bishop that they'll pass the message on to.
And the church will be reeling with Joseph, what is on offer.
So, November the 9th, 1906.
The effects of meditation continuously on the passion.
This is really good now for the hours of the passion, okay?
Finding myself in my usual state, I was thinking about the passion of our Lord.
And while I was doing this, he came and he told me, my daughter,
one who meditates continuously on my passion and feels sorrow for it,
and compassion for me pleases me very much.
That I feel as though comforted for all that I suffered in the course of my passion.
And by always meditating on it, the soul arrives at preparing a continuous food.
In this food, there are many different spices and flavors which form different effects.
So, if in the course of my passion they gave me ropes and chains to tie me,
the soul releases me and gives me freedom.
They despise me, they spat on me, and they dishonored me.
She appreciates me, cleans me of that spittle and honors me,
which you'll hear her describing in the hours of the passion.
They stripped me and scourged me, she heals me and clothes me.
They crowned me with torns, mocking me as king,
embittered my mouth with bile and crucified me.
While the soul, meditating on all my pains, crowns me with glory and honors me as her king,
fills my mouth with sweetness, giving me the most delicious food which is the memory of my own works.
And, unnailing me from the cross, she makes me rise again in her heart.
And every time she does so, I give her a new life of grace and recompense.
Notice every time you do the hours of the passion.
She is my food and I become her continuous food.
So, the thing that pleases me the most is meditating continuously on the passion.
Okay?
So, November the 12th, 1906.
The soul gives Jesus a dwelling in time and he gives the soul a dwelling in eternity.
In the ancient liturgy that we have abandoned, we used to say,
"O admirably Commirtium, what a wonderful exchange."
That you give the Lord a dwelling in time and he gives you a dwelling in eternity.
So, if you don't want to write it in Latin, write it in English, what a wonderful exchange.
Okay?
And the expression was used in terms of we give him bread and he gives us back himself.
"O admirably Commirtium."
Admirably, of course, is it "mirable" is what you say in English.
And "commertium" is "commerce."
Yeah.
There's things going on.
So, continuing in my usual state, I was saying to bless Jesus,
"Oh, how I wish to love you and to be loved more by you."
That's the essence of it all.
It's all about love.
The 36 volumes is all about divine will and divine love.
And he and my interior told me, "I love you so much that I never leave you
and I dwell in you continuously."
There's your 1 Corinthians 3, 16 again.
And Louisa said, "Thank you for your kindness in dwelling in me,
but I am not so content.
I would be more content and would feel safer if I could dwell in you,"
which, of course, is the secret of living in the divine will.
He said, "Am I daughter in time?"
And you could say, "On earth, you give a dwelling to me
and in eternity I give it to you."
Now, the Lord started that plan way back in Exodus when he taught the people
how to set up a tabernacle for him, how to set up a liturgy,
how to have commerce, you know, you give me something, I give you something.
And all of that is the basis for our divine liturgies and so on.
And so you give me a dwelling in time,
and they've always called the tabernacle of the Lord,
the most sacred place on earth.
And in eternity I give it to you.
So in eternity is John 14 verses 1 to 2.
In my Father's house there are many rooms, and there's one for you.
Revelation 21, 3, the new Jerusalem, and there's a place in it for you.
Hebrews 9 verses 11 and 12.
Acts 7, 44.
7, 44.
And Exodus 25, 40.
Now you could go on, but that's enough.
In other words, he really meant it.
Okay.
"And be well content and sure," Jesus said,
"that the one who dwells in you has the power to maintain your dwelling
that is fortified and free of any danger."
So the secret is to really set up that dwelling, you know,
and let the Lord be in charge.
So we have a very short one for November the 14th, 1906.
Oh, how I struggled and suffered because of Jesus' privation.
Then after a long time he made himself seen just in passing,
and he told me, "My daughter, if perfect resignation is the certain
and sure sign of predestination,
the cross expands the boundaries of the kingdom of heaven."
In other words, the cross enables you to grow and grow
and expand your territory.
Now it's almost a quarter past eight.
Next one is long.
Do you want me to do it or wait?
Leave it up the next day.
then at November the 16th.